once you solve for y equals x and this
parabola you get you two points and that
will be where let's take that away that
we wear your point of intersection right
finally we're in the main meal and we
can have a look at what this last
question is possible let n be a negative
real number so let's actually do this so
much I'm going to say let's and we
actually have notation for this right so
I could say a real number but I want a
number minus sign there I have pointed
out you don't have to know this notation
but it's just faster don't say that okay
and then they say find f inverse of f of
n now the reason why this is a question
at all and it requires us to a platform
is because if this is the case there's
something weird going on right because I
shouldn't be thinking about this F
inverse business with any negative
numbers right like the earlier parts of
the question told me I can't restrict
the he restricted there and when you
told me you domain and range restriction
everything else demanded everything kept
me in the first quadrant all right so
everything is positive so how can this
even be meaningful right well we need to
think about it okay and I will show you
the way we're doing what we're going to
take advantage of is the symmetry of the
graph that we're going to that we kind
of causes a problem before yeah like I
need to ignore this part of the graph
right we're not gonna ignore it now so
here's what I'm going to ask you to do
draw for me if you haven't already of
this parabola okay let's see what it
looks like and we're gonna try to draw
some pockets here's it I don't need any
like a super detailed compass or
anything like that
I'm gonna simplify this form of it so
that we can get out what's going on now
remember we point yeah
okay this is a problem so we've met
functions that have axes a surgery
before and when the axis of symmetry is
x equals zero we even call them a give
them a special name we call them even
functions right now this is not
beautiful but it's very very similar to
an even function all right what's the
rule for an even function what's the
definition we looked at it just f of X
equals F of negative x now that is not
the case here okay
but there is an axis of symmetry x
equals 2 so how do I take advantage of
this ok let's think about this I can
take here if if a value is over here
like say f of 3 I have no idea what it's
actually for value meters but whatever
it is it should be the same as f of
whatever is on the other side now my
scale has been here in this I'm sorry
about length ok but if you go one unit
this way but you should go under unit so
that way do you agree with that so
therefore I can say for this particular
function which is not even I can say F
of 1 is equal to every 3 right like
that's the symmetry that has around x
equals 2 does that make sense
I'm I could go further as well that's
going one unit left and one you two
right I can go three this left two units
right and I see this degree that and I
can keep on going as far as I'd like so
what am I trying to see well this
clearly a pattern it's sort of like this
pattern but not quite because the
answers are so choose like x equals 0
right how can I make them really feel
well
remember we said how did I get how do I
get one two three where those numbers
come from yeah I started from 2 and then
I want with plus or minus in fact it's a
lot like what we did with cosine digital
solutions remember that so really what
this is is f of you start from - and
then you went to the left 1 unit then
you send stuff to and go 1 unit to the
right instead
and now once you write it like this even
though it's a bit awkward and clearly we
can simplify the numbers it actually
helps you see what pattern is going on
right instead if I want to go two units
further out I'm gonna say F of 2 minus 2
is f are two persons that make sense and
in the same way you can't emulate this
pattern okay
the pattern is nice I've noticed it I've
got my 1 2 3 values right so how might
generalize this for any value of x that
I stick in here right I can say look go
to the left to go to the right and these
two pieces of intercept right so
therefore I can say F of 2 minus X is F
of 2 plus X does that make sense
so now just have a look at that this is
not the main point I'm going to draw but
just have a look at how this relates to
that you see what's going on in fact
this is a special case of this the
significance of two of course is as the
axis of symmetry right the axis of
symmetry is in here - it's just kind of
hidden or is that two symmetry there
it's Europe this is f of 0 plus X
because f of 0 minus X does that make
sense you go to the left right and they
should be the same ok yeah I've just
changed where the axis is so that's why
it's all to me
now how do I use this to make sense of
this because remember we're saying well
you shouldn't be able to put negative
values in there because my
infrastructure does exist it well if you
have a look at this line this one I just
written if I choose an appropriate
substitution I can stick negative
numbers in its dignity
he's the way I'm gonna do it see how
there's a negative there so I don't want
you to put something into here to take
advantage of this negative here right
because double negatives will cancel and
they will leave things as positive and
I'm good with that
I want I want positive numbers out of
this so the question is what would be an
appropriate substitution now you can
sort of look around a little bit and I
did a bit of trial and error before I
said it on what I wanted because I want
some things to cancel
here's what I'm gonna introduce I'm
gonna let X equal to take away them okay
now this isn't both immediately obvious
to be okay but again I took a few
minutes to think it through and then
it's sort of emerged if I let X equal
that now but the only reason I'm
treating capital N is because the
question has chosen okay I'm just gonna
substitute that straight into this slime
which is all about this asymmetry okay
so what does the left-hand side become
like just do the straight so there's no
single fine once again it's gonna be to
take away stupid separately and then on
the right hand side yeah okay now what
happens over with insight now we're
ready to simplify 2 minus 2 of course it
is zero zero so I don't have to want
that and then you've got a double
negative no this is the bit that I
wanted right that's it
does that make sense yep what happens I
run this ahead of time
huh now here's the thing right
I can't is this negative real number
that they're suggesting right I can't
really work with this right because what
will come out is something that's
outside the range of this guy like he
doesn't exist this so I can't use this
but I can use this
this guy's fine he can take negative
values just fine because then 4 minus n
turns than positive does that make sense
so usually I would say I'm gonna go back
to for one more time the question I
would usually say f inverse of M or n
right by definition if I say n is um is
in the domain that I just I would
usually just say n right but I can't do
that because it's outside the range that
I want right you can't possibly end up
with a negative number but this guy
because we've seen the graph I've said
this the demo so therefore you're not in
this domain you have to be in this
domain right since and is less than zero
right
if n is less than zero you can't go
ahead with that because any of us would
never possibly hand you a value that's
negative right but it can't handie
values that are positive if you take 4
minus n right because 4 minus m to the
double negative cancels so you get your
stop for 4 and then 5 6 7
sir what are we done you can actually
try this out right you actually put
about you in let's let's go one more
time guys okay um someone choose a
negative real number for me negative 5
okay that's really far away but that's
alright so I'm gonna GERD sorry x equals
okay right so there's our life alight
now because you're really gonna have to
adjust the reason why I put in x equals
negative 5 is because I want where as
here is if all negative 5 okay so you
look at them oh you're way over here
right now
when you say x equals that you're like
this unit is at the inverse of effort
that I shouldn't be able to hand back
negative 5 because I'm invested over
here he can't hate you negative 5 it's
outside his range okay so therefore what
I'm saying is f inverse of f of 5 so
negative 5 it can't possibly be negative
5 it can't the end right what is f of 5
actually equal to
it's like that value there right so this
is f inverse of like other nine eleven
and a half or something like that F
inverse mm-hmm Jebus of eleven and a
half right so then I say eleven and a
half he's actually okay he exists he's
positive for the black wire right he's
just in that domain so I go over to
eleven and a half
well I'm just gonna roughly do it x
equals eleven point five so there is
over there right I did it as best as I
could so what is f inverse of eleven
half approximately is inverse I'm
looking at the inverse function and X's
and putting in X's right um based on my
reading of the graph it's about five
sorry it's that line isn't it there's
ten how about one unit down if you can
see that I'm just gonna go ahead and
take right now where does that name come
from
it's up its four take away negative five
you see that F inverse of F of this
negative number can't hand you negative
five because the black line doesn't
exist down here okay but it does exist
if you take advantage of this symmetry
which actually makes everything for you
and that's the algebra that gets you
it's a really hard question um it takes
some twists and turns to get there right
like probably you thought someplace
how on earth was I supposed to see that
okay
I bet your be exceptionally cool for
your sword but I'm showing it to you
because it's actually really it's really
cool it's like it's from being described
because to understand like these
symmetry pieces and putting stuff into
the functions and then what you get out
is easy to test wasn't it but just pick
any value works if it ends up being
useful to you yes now will point out it
usually is like you don't need to
usually go to those these kinds of
lengths to do anything with players
because we're so good at well you know
we're prowlers tend to go as
parametric's like you've seen that
before that's ready to follow but this
is a very particular case because of the
inverse functions and stuff the domain
restriction that's actually kind of cool
like you can get one half from the other
I shouldn't see them around actually you
can get you can get this half from this
half so what I'm trying to extrapolate
is what's kind of happening down here
right I excluded that from my domain but
the original function still works there
so I should be able to make some
conclusions